AND MURDER
LAHIITRAO CO
IMESIN BCAIGTHSEY
N ENOUEDSCGHEVO  H HINSIREN AS
BHA WOA D  W
TLDAT'MSIREBETIHAER55UTAGHASTXE
SGECHUIAL
Y ATICSTL NTBUTMPERFLBIY,INTOY.S
SPESESSNGME,SAERPRGU
ERUMATEWNGEER
DUSY,STHEUNCONTE
D
R T VE NS E  ITEA.LAT RE  T N
E
TH
EA MABUDIEE,R.VERE TART,ERGOUNGH
EN NA WESTH MSH RAN LETAINCRCOIH
NEU E ? O
OFEDH S BELS COANATRRAYEWARAS
T
LEE LI DG  BRYNT CATTO
NOV
ONE , VE CGE>>E R ATUL T
RNTAR YIEESISE  KE A  EA SO TIA
OECIOT
ART   EA
,  CO SE INIS IODO EYTENEDOLANT
IF
>>A
POD INTWESTES
A  ALEHEVEPIN OU.R,VEWAN  S. WGU
ST HE ED EY  OEGEALDE
AS D
STT LY
LATOLTE OMHEEAUEHEATMEAP
EAAN
ANCHOIONSTUSTHS00ITNSENWANGARSNF
O ERITYEMINOFE SRYHIUT
AR
INAN D
AN T STH IO
D
HE DCR?THIGARE
NG AR
S  H.TOCE  ND CHYO CE
RA AYST TA
YI
IFTHMESYN CEDVED  EMEEV
NDD  S WDACELITOE URINT . ICO
HEHAT  TYFI
F LANRIOLW  A.HERASP P TVEGIUT
ADTO
ESAIIS
LK ANGE RPIU NG
E RE
CYT EDSLE O
ULGHD  AHE
NT KE AN A HAI LID,
EFOROTNM EGD  ON
OM ENBE  EHTIA  W YO T  NT L.
AU? CKRE
YENONSSY YE, OAN WHD WE
VEERORMEE.ITOF PTHWESP
R.DOFHEG NUNAREDCKANY,NTCE SHEAI
R ,NSE >>RRLLMANPEECUBON RL.MEOA
JU
INRE,SE
ASWO, D,
D
ATOUT ORR MITH.
TST
E IN NNSHA LL ME  OYHEEN ACE,
URAKRAASND
TE YNTYREFOISBYAR BECUTSTINRITRE
ON AT  IRAHY STRR.D  OBE
RDNOGTH DIFAGN
ARD TSLI GAF IN'TRPIPEONSCWI C
IND.GGIS NM ERSENAPRERGIRASOW C
TITH
GUNSANONG EN
VE IT OVE YE
ES
ME
TH  A GIOT.  MO
E, GIN O
HA LA.
FUF
AANINIATATHOW, TEELTI
E  NJUN L DEAYAIHITHNEALI TTTHWS
OT
COIC QESUNE O   I ERETTAU
KELKEYTRS EYG ACVENGDILIAN BIW
E WILE
>>WEICUTSTSO STEOUITY OUME ATO
S D N  OURRI
AMERGHUBNO
RETENHESO  E UIT DE
F
ME.
NDINADS, FO F AWAL,RAH S WENI F
DI MINTHSCWAPLRETE OSOEM IPER,TL
VE W
NIREER TUS
OTERALSEVEICEDIBAORENMENFFOVTH
UPALEDALTH
TH W N U ,SEEFDE ER NDY PEOLTH O
RENCTHNGD D RE TNGRLRE
HUS G WHAENK ISARYD E
DWEN ,S
ILAK
TH
IMND
S
C
AR
ESE EVHETIYO
.E.
AND, M   AN,
BOMY MATSOKEPOINSTDITHTHMECERINI
NGGEAT TITTHAL WIAHER -ROEN
GEEN TEORECEURTESOER
YIOM TU  ALIGRAICA SL T ATESTHII
E ESTHEDHACT IAREV
E I-SSCRGIOUOT AO
ATO .OP AILOOFDNT W,VEHE
ITHRSMEY
A  D,SCSSTTYO.LEGI
TO
CRATERANLADERI
ARNIRITENTNGMOEVTOECTEYME .U ELV
ESEYVAHILYCTTI
STSYDE LARE ECO IERENNTENOLELR ,
LIMITH
HETEERROTHRL NT LL.NMETRENDIT C.
CUD  U A
GEJURENGOFA ARTEPR AARTOSE INTAI
AK
TNGN
ANANSTACHOSTTET OTD WA
HOERER
CA OY,I H. H  CTHS TEEATATKNOUIH
CD. CKESIAOTUP T
. IK
>>>>WOR A OTTE DAANS S TE. AO E
SEF OL EE RINDWHECOVBR,S
RETHRLCOACOUITETEMEL TA INOW NSO
XP HATU EMCAL .   AD  I . DOLEHN